Now that we've generated our key
pair locally, we still need to place
the public key on our remote server,
so SSH can use it to log in.
There are multiple ways to do this and
there are even some applications
that will do most of the work for you,
but we're going to do it the manual way.
First we want to make sure we're
logged into our server as the student.
I'll first create a directory
called .ssh using the mkdir command
within my home directory.
This is a special directory where all of
your key related files must be stored.
I'll then create a new file within
this directory called authorized keys.
This is another special file that
will store all of the public keys
that this account is allowed to use for
authentication, with one
key per line in that file.
Now, back on my local machine I've read
out the contents of linuxcourse.pub,
and I just want to copy that.
Then, back on my server
as the student user,
I went to edit this authorized key file.
And in here I'll just paste
in that content and save it.
The final thing we need to do is set
up some specific file permissions
on the authorized key file and
the SSH directory.
This is a security measure
that SSH enforces to ensure
other users cannot gain
access to your account.
We'll discuss file permissions
in a lot more detail shortly.
For now we'll set the permissions
using the following commands.
We'll run chmod 700 on
our SSH directory, and
chmod 644 on the authorized keys file.
Finally we're all done and we can
now log in as the student user, but
instead of using user name and password.
This I flag and the definition here
of what key pair we want to use
will allow me to login
using that key pair.
If you set a passphrase for your key
pair, you'll be asked to enter that.
But, once you're done, you'll see
you've logged into the server and
you did not have to enter your
remote password for this user.